in a horrific act of anti-muslim
terrorism a 48 year old man drove a van
into a group of Muslims near a mosque in
Finsbury Park in London on Sunday he
shouted I want to kill all Muslims I did
my bit you deserve it
one man was killed 10 others were
wounded according to the Daily Mail
quote the unnamed man who was
clean-shaven with curly hair and wore
white t-shirt suffered cuts to his face
in hands and was films repeatedly
shouting killing me - the men who
grabbed him after his arrest the terror
suspect continued to goad the crowds
that witnessed the attack by smiling
waving and even blowing kisses at them
the incidents horrific the perpetrator
should spend the rest of his life in
prison because the UK has no death
penalty the left isn't wrong to connect
it with an upsurge in anti-muslim crime
according to London Mayor Sadiq Khan who
has been far too permissive with regard
to Islamic radicalism on his own soil he
released police figures that showed
according to Newsweek quote Islamophobic
attacks had risen fivefold since the
ramming and knife assault a 40% increase
in racist attacks the numbers from
London's Metropolitan Police show that
anti-muslim motivated incidents had
risen to a daily 2017 average of four to
as many as 20 but it is wrong to use the
anti-muslim attack as justification for
the equivalency between the dangers of
the rise of radical Islam and the rise
of anti-muslim xenophobia that is absurd
yes attacks on Muslims have risen and
that is unjustifiable and awful major
attacks on Muslims by anti Muslim
terrorists are far less common however
than major radical Muslim attacks on
non-muslims across Europe and they are
supported by no major terrorist group
let alone state actors radical Muslims
run States anti Muslim countries do not
exist in the same way even the most
extreme anti Muslim countries have
Muslim populations for example this
London attack marks the first major
terror attack in Great Britain against
Muslims since 2013 when a ukrainian
student attempted to bomb a mosque in
birmingham and stabs young muslim man to
death if I miss when I apologize in
advance in the last four months however
we have seen the Westminster terror
attack - Manchester Arena bombing and
the London Bridge attack this is not to
suggest that violent anti-muslim terror
attacks are somehow better or less
disgusting
than violent radical Muslim terror
attacks on others but they are far less
statistically frequent have nearly no
global support and earn the round
condemnation of the entire Western world
the left has attempted to broaden the
conversation to include into
you'll hate crimes for example harassing
a woman in the hijab but if we do that
we also have to include the rate of hate
crimes by Muslims against others eg Jews
across Europe we have a moral obligation
to fight against terrorism wherever we
see it but to pretend that a widespread
anti-muslim terror network is spreading
across the West
organized or disorganized is a
deliberate misreading of the situation
by people who are politically motivated
to wave away the continuing threat of
radical Muslim terrorism i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
all right so we have a lot to talk about
today I want to talk about what looks
like it could be looming war over Syria
president Trump seems to be in a
position where the Russians are now
trying to push him around in Syria so
we'll talk about that momentarily we'll
also talk about megyn kelly and Alex
Jones and I want to talk a fair bit
today about the situation with these
alt-right protesters storming the stage
Julius Caesar at Shakespeare in the
parks I think it's indicative of
something else that's happening in the
modern right-wing movement that is
troubling to say the least but before we
get to any of that I first want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at MVM t
/ MV m t so movement watches was founded
on the belief that style should not
break the bank and this watch right here
which I wear every single day it is an
awesome awesome watch you can see it
really classy and minimalist that is
their design they've sold over a million
watches to consumers in 160 countries
around the world I love this watch it
gets compliments all the time it's
lightweight but it but it's really sleek
and and solid as well feels great and
looks great and that the company is
started by two broke college kids that
want to wear stylish watches but they
couldn't afford them so they started
their own watch company instead they
start at just 95 dollars at a department
store you're looking at a four hundred
five hundred dollar watch these started
like 95 bucks this one right here I
think is like 150 bucks which is really
not bad for a super quality watch
inexpensive really great they figured
out that by selling online they can cut
out the middleman they don't get the
mark up at your local department store
again they've already sold over a
million watches and you get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns if you go to MVM t.com slash
shapiro that's MV mt movement MVM
t-dot-com
slash shapiro make sure you use the
slash appear you get 15% off your order
today MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro and
also that will ensure that they know
that we sent you so they'll continue to
advertise the program and make it
possible for us to do the show okay so
lots and lots of breaking news happening
in in the news today so we talked about
this terror attack in London I want to
lead off with that specifically because
I think it's important for those of us
who are on the right to point out when
these sorts of attacks occur because
terror is terror is terror that doesn't
mean the terror movements are all the
same this doesn't mean the terror
is the same danger from all quarters but
it is important to mention when a terror
attack like this occurs because
otherwise we are not being we're not
being objective or honest in in what's
happening around the world
other big news today is that the the
Russian government is basically now
threatening war with the United States
over Syria which is you know I think
that they're bluffing I think there's a
pretty solid shot that they are bluffing
but it's dangerous anyway obviously
right now if you if you look at the
situation basically in Syria
you've got the Kurds all the way up in
the north and then in the West you have
the you have ie I mean in the East you
have Isis which is this big block of
territory in the east and then the rest
of the country sort of the everywhere
from the southeast to the northwest is
split between the Free Syrian Army that
would be the Syrian rebels and Bashar
Assad's government Bashar Assad's
government is being propped up right now
by Vladimir Putin so here's the
situation according to CNN on Sunday an
American jet shot down a a Syrian
jet the shoot down came a little more
than two hours after forces allied with
the Syrian regime of Bashar al-assad
attacked the north central Syria town of
Jadine which was controlled by the
Syrian Defense Forces in accordance with
rules of engagement and in collective
self-defense of coalition partner forces
the Syrian jet was immediately shot down
by a US f f/a 18 super hornets I hope
that I'm reading that correctly and in
case we shot down a Syrian jet and the
Russians immediately threatened
retaliation the Russian Defense Ministry
announced quote all kinds of airborne
vehicles including aircraft and UAVs of
the International Coalition detected
west of the Euphrates River which
includes part of Iraq will be tracked by
the Russian sa M systems as air targets
so they're threatening to start shooting
down American planes once they start
threatened to shoot down American planes
then we are on the brink of war which is
obviously a frightening scenario this
was created by Barack Obama this has
nothing to do with President Trump
President Trump did say during the
campaign to Hillary Clinton that her
attempt to her suggestion that we set up
a no-fly zone over Syria could lead to
World War 3 now it appears that we are
engaging in an air war with Syrians that
is I think a bad move actually by
President Trump and I think we have to
acknowledge the risks that are
here David French has suggested
partition of the country we support the
Kurds up north to create in their own
independent state and that we guarantee
air coverage over that area and that we
guarantee air coverage over various
other areas but we're playing a
dangerous game of chicken with the
Russians and this is all because Barack
Obama never had a Russian strategy a
Syrian strategy and didn't do anything
back in 2013 when he could have and
should have so again I can't blame
President Trump for this and I won't
blame President Trump for a situation he
was handed by his unbelievably
incompetent predecessor again I don't
think there's any long-lasting great
solution here but the only solution here
is going to be something that nobody
really likes very much okay so the big
news over the weekend at least in the
domestic political area was that there
are these alt-right protesters who have
decided to run up on stage with the
Julius Caesar production and Shakespeare
in the park now we talked about this
production last week this is the
production where the Julius Caesar part
is staged clearly as president Trump his
wife is staged clearly as Melania Trump
and then he is assassinated now for
those who don't know the play the basic
concept of the plays that Julius Caesar
is has overweening ambition but is
assassinated by a bunch of senators who
want to restore the Republic and then
the entire thing breaks down the
assassination of Caesar is not seen in a
particularly good light in the play the
assassination of Caesar is seen as a big
mistake by Brutus Cassius and all the
conspirators and the Roman mob is
basically whipped into a frenzy by Mark
Antony to permanently end democracy and
Republic and republicanism in Rome so at
the very least you know if you read the
play it is not clear that the play is in
favor of Trump quote from Caesar being
assassinated but the imagery is
disturbing obviously we played it last
week and it I think is an obvious and
silly representation by the by the
people who decided to do the play it is
not however linked and this is this
annoys me
it is not advocacy or defensive violence
and it is not linked it is not linked to
the assassination attempt on
congressional members by this far-left
anti-trump guy there is no evidence
whatsoever that he went and saw the
plane that was inspired to do this even
if there had been I'm deeply
uncomfortable with this notion that if
you listen to Sean Hannity or Rush
Limbaugh and then you go shoot somebody
that is Sean Hannity or Rush Limbaugh's
fault if they are not advocating
violence it is not their fault okay this
is a game that we can we can play
all day long but it's a stupid game and
it's a counterproductive game so
nonetheless there are a bunch of people
who want to get their name in the paper
so they've decide they're gonna rush up
onstage at these events now I am against
as a general rule snowflake er II of all
forms I don't like when people rush on
stage when I am speaking I would be a
hypocrite if I said it was ok for people
to rush on stage when someone else is
speaking the justification people use
when they rush up on stage and try to
shut down my speeches or Ann Coulter
speeches or milos or Charles Murray's or
ayaan Hirsi Ali s or Heather McDonald
whenever they do this what they say is
they're trying to prevent hate speech
because that hate speech will generate
violence this is always their excuse
always and here is what it looks like
when they do these things and it is bad
ok this is what happened at Cal State LA
back in February 2015 here is what
happened and this is how it's written
you will and there it is gang guess what
you know what they're not going to stop
us
they pulled the fire alarm in the middle
of the speech we had footage but there's
a big riot outside basically people were
assaulting people in the crowd
it was disgusting then it is disgusting
now ok here is protesters blocking the
stage at University of Wisconsin this is
very similar to what just happened in
Shakespeare in the Park
I was speaking at University of
Wisconsin a bunch of protesters decided
to get up and shout at me and disrupt
the proceedings that police wouldn't do
anything about it and then they all
stood in front of the stage and they
started blocking the proceedings here's
what that look like ok so again you know
this notion that I'm unfamiliar with
people doing this sort of thing is
ridiculous or the notion that I am
somehow against this sort of stuff
because of cowardice I go on college
campus campuses all the time and I speak
to crowds in which this kind of stuff
occurs it is always stupid it is always
gross it is all these counts are
productive it is always anti-free speech
over to pol university I risked arrest
to walk onto campus here is what it
looked like when they when the
administration there decided that they
would not let me even enter the campus
to speak now I want to point something
out after they informed me that they
would arrest me because it would be
trespassing it's a private universe
I don't have a right to be there so I
left here is what that looked like just
to be just to be clear if I attempt to
enter that hall right there and sit down
just to listen to somebody speak or if I
attempt to ask a questions or to engage
in free speech you will have me arrested
at this point no sir okay and so I took
all of the people from DePaul we went to
a place off campus where we then
proceeded to engage in our free speech
events anyway so all of that is prelude
to what happened at Shakespeare and
Parker the reason I put that out there
is number one because I have lived this
experience many times and number two
because it is wrong when the left does
it and it is similarly stupid and wrong
when the right does it okay here is what
happened this is on Friday evening the
the thing is Jack puss a bigot did but I
don't really know how to who he is or
his name until he started tweeting at me
and Laura Laura
Lauren Jeb Big Jim don't know who they
are but in any case they stormed the
stage and they make a big deal out of it
and now they're raising all sorts of
money for themselves here's the first
alt right storming of the stage
thank you Jeff and we're going to pause
we're going to pause security security
please
[Music]
[Applause]
they're shouting the birla hate kills
and this is violence and then possibly
Jabba do he gets up and he starts
shouting how everybody is gabbles and
everyone here is a Nazi everyone here is
gabbles because they've come to watch a
production of Julius Caesar in which the
current leader of the country is
portrayed as Julius Caesar which by the
way happened in 2011 when a Minneapolis
theatre portrayed President Obama as
this now I thought it was ridiculous and
stupid when the left went insane after a
rodeo clown in Missouri dressed up as
president to Obama the left went nuts it
was ridiculous then it is ridiculous now
for people to go crazy over a piece of
art that they don't like it's really
really stupid but that's not stopping
the right from now engaging in the same
sort of snowflake worry and Mick let me
make something clear
okay people have been acting like this
is oh well you know we're just using
their tactics against them no that's not
what this is okay that's not what this
is because even if the left stops
shutting down my speeches or an speeches
or my low speeches or any of the rest of
these presumably these all trekt
protestors would still go and do this
stuff they would still go into it why
not because they're trying to
demonstrate that the tactic is wrong
they're doing it because they are
offended by the content which makes them
right-wing snowflakes although they're
not even really right-wing because I
have yet to identify their right-wing
principles other than that they don't
like the left it's just it's just insane
here's the Laura Ingraham tweeting about
this that she tweeted quote the left
doesn't like it when their tactics are
used against their expression how many
would storm stage if Obama was stabbed
okay first of all in Minneapolis none of
them stormed the stage but second of all
if they did I would say that was bad and
stupid I would say that is a dumb thing
to do because you don't have a right to
destroy people's place of business you
don't have a right to interfere with
someone else's freedom of speech now
this is not the same thing as
establishing a mutually assured
destruction
with regard to boycotts for example I
have a right to do with my money what I
want you have the right to do with your
money what you want if you want to
boycott chick-fil-a and I want a boycott
MSNBC that is perfectly within our
purview what I cannot do and what you
cannot do you can't walk down to
chick-fil-a occupy the place okay when
black lives matter did that to a bunch
of brunches in New York City it was
stupid it was counterproductive and it
was gross and by the way it led people
to react by electing
Trump Trump's response to this kind of
behavior by the way was not to go and
shut down leftist events it was to point
out that the left was shutting down his
events which was eminently correct so
for all the people who keep saying well
we have to use their strategies because
they're winning no they are not they've
lost over a thousand seats all across
the country Trump is the president and
we in Republicans control the the
Congress as well as the Senate the
notion that the left is winning because
of an Tifa snowflakes because of the
people at University of Wisconsin
shutting things down
it's just idiocy it's just idiocy so no
that's not even strategically is not
some sort of strategic genius so they do
it again on Sunday night and of course
again because so much of the right has
become tribal instead of smart or
conservative there are a lot of people
who have defended this activity which
I'll show you in a second so here's the
second protester jumping on stage on
Sunday night
[Applause]
liberal hate kills liberal hate kills
I've been on the receiving end of this
routine from the left okay verbiage does
not kill words are not violence and the
minute preached in sness for years okay
the minute you start suggesting that
words are violence we grow ever closer
to violence the minute you start
suggesting that simple political
discourse discourse you don't like is
equivalent to violence then you are
justifying violence in the name of
shutting down that discourse it's
disgusting and it's wrong okay it's
wrong and it's just as wrong as when the
left does it I don't understand why I
have to explain this to people who are
conservative that are supposed to be
grounded in a judeo-christian value
system that suggests the value of other
human beings and the value of free
speech it's really quite disgusting and
horrifying okay then a guy gets up and
he starts yelling that CNN is Isis at
this situation again very helpful
I just wanna point something out every
keeps shouting about Devils okay let me
point them how about Devils and the
Nazis what they actually used to do is
shut down Marxist events okay if there
was a Marxist political event they would
send stormtroopers to shut it down
and not when they were in the knot when
they were elected okay like independent
little ant Aoife type groups this is
just it's just on but Sean Hannity who
again I love Sean Hannity as a person
but Sean is is I think I think he's
pandering to the worst group of people
on the right Sean Hannity tweets this
right so Sean is tweeting about this
last night I tweeted that this this has
to stay he tweeted wild might liberal
hate kills chance protester okay now
Sean gives opinions for a living he has
an opinion host he is not an objective
journalist when I called him on this and
I said this is this is I said the left
chance conservative hate conservative
hate kills and you call them snowflakes
which is right stop with this stupidity
and then Sean tweeted back been the only
person being stupid here is you I was
tweeting exactly what was said with
video I'm mature enough to let people
decide but you have an opinion you have
an opinion on this Sean I mean and then
later Sean did express his opinion which
is that he thinks it's perfectly fine
that they shut this thing down because
it was disrespectful to the President of
the United States and in his opinion it
was forwarding violence again I'm gonna
be god forbid somebody should shoot a
person on the Left who and the shooter
happens to be somebody who once
listening to Sean Hannity show I was
somebody who two weeks ago two freakin
weeks ago two weeks ago folks I was
sitting here defending Sean Hannity from
boycott over the Seth rich stuff okay
but the entire left was going after him
and what did Sean say he said just
because I was covering store in a
particular way doesn't mean that the
left retargeting me for destruction okay
so that all of this is is highly
irritating and I want to talk about a
few more points I have to make on this
before I get to and I how the left has
reacted to the shooting because the left
is reacting just as abysmally as you
would expect them to but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
upside calm so if you are into traveling
if you are a business traveler
particularly upside calm is for you
every time you buy a trip it upside you
save a lot of money and
give you an Amazon gift card worth 100
200 even $300 every single time so the
flight is cheaper for your company and
then you also get the Amazon gift card
that comes directly to you not just to
your company what they do is they bundle
your flight and your hotel for one price
they can offer you all sorts of options
if you take a different flight if you
come into a different Airport if you go
to a different hotel it saves money
especially on business travel because
it's mostly for people who are traveling
by themselves on business travel if
you're doing that there's no better
company than upside comm if you are
shopping for business or personal travel
as well it takes three minutes to see
how much you can save go over to upside
comm and check it out
I spoke with the founder of the company
and jaywalker and he is just a genius he
was he was very I think was the founder
of one of the other major travel sites
and upside is sort of the next step in
travel so if you use my name Ben right
now you are guaranteed to get at least a
$200 Amazon gift card for your very
first trip my name Ben and it gets you
that $200 Amazon gift card free save big
on travel get a big gift card every
single trip upside calm upside calm
minimum purchase required I'm sorry it's
a $100 gift gift card for your first
trip minimum purchase required see the
site for complete details upside calm
and make sure that you use my name Ben
get that $100 Amazon gift card for free
and you can go check it out right now
and remember use that promo code okay so
a couple of more points on this because
I think that this is important I think
he goes deep to the heart of what the
conservative movement wants to be do we
want to be a movement that suggests that
we are going to shut down the left when
we don't like what they say or are we
going to be a movement that actually has
some principles now there are a lot of
people on the right who have been who
started using this phrase my principles
muh principles ma print light as opposed
to my principles and the idea is that
you're a baby because you're whining
about more principles oh you have
principles too if you're one of these
people your principles too but you need
to name them for me because those
principles obviously don't include the
idea that you don't get to destroy
somebody's establishment just because
you don't like what they're saying I
assume and now you say your principle is
winning that's not a principle that is a
goal okay a principle is something that
you are willing to lose to uphold okay
what are you willing to sacrifice in
order to uphold the principle I am
willing to sacrifice the notion that a
play offends me
based on the principle that you
shouldn't shut down free speech even for
people I don't like I'm willing to
sacrifice that by the way I don't think
they're winning because of that
hey freedom of speech speech is a
principle storming my speeches storming
place it is wrong it's wrong whether we
do it it is wrong whether they do it not
the same thing as an economic boycott
and there's that other principle that I
mentioned too that words are not
violence I've spent my entire career
saying words are not violence the left
says they are violence and now we've got
half the right saying that words are
violence this is the predicate to
legislation to tamp down on speech in
order this is how you get to Canada you
wanna know how you gets a Canadian
version of free speech or people get
sued for things that they don't like
okay the reason is because they're a
bunch of people who say that it causes
violence and then there's the tactical
argument so my friend John Nolte who I
love John okay but John wrote this piece
today attacking me by name and because
at daily wire I want to have a site
where we have a multiplicity of
viewpoints I printed it he used them up
principles line I printed it I disagreed
with every word of it including and and
the he talks about how these people
storming Julius Caesar it was like
Lincoln suspending habeas corpus okay
this this is just ridiculous to me for a
couple of reasons one Lincoln suspended
habeas corpus during an actual Civil War
like there was a war on if we're gonna
use wartime morality in peacetime we're
pretty soon gonna be in a war like it'll
be an actual war if we use wartime
morality in peacetime
okay don't quote Sherman unless you're
willing to burn Atlanta furthermore - if
we're gonna pretend that the left is
winning because they as John says break
windows her legs shoot us shout us down
they're not they're losing because of
all of this the more extreme the left
becomes the more they lose the left
insanity drove the right to victory
across the country let's not pretend the
Donald Trump came along and suddenly the
right one the right had won a thousand
seats across the country the right had
won back the house and the Senate before
Donald Trump was even mentioned as a
presidential candidate okay Trump did a
lot of good things one of the things he
did was he called out the West when he
did this stuff one of the things he did
not do was attempt to shut down left his
speech John asked for a plan he said so
what's your plan if you're not storming
stages here's my plan
speak on college campuses point out to
the press as loudly and as often as
possible when they refuse to allow us to
speak and by the way it works Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren Barack Obama
all have come out against the college
snow flake er II that is now being
evidenced from the right
and finally there's a morality of the
tactics question okay some of these
tactics are just not moral okay they are
not doing this again because they are
attempting to stop the left from doing
it they are doing it because they are
offended if you are trying to shut down
someone's free speech because you are
offended you are the problem
you are the snowflake you're the person
doing something wrong okay now as we
continue here I want to talk about the
the left's response to the shootings
because the fallout from that is just
insane the left has lost its mind as
well but in order for you to see that
you're gonna have to go over and
subscribe over it's a Lee Weyer com $8 a
month got to go subscription to daily
wire lots of extra goodies coming that
we are planning you see we're moving
into our new studios here it is not
gonna actually be this funeral home
where we are currently doing the show
but there's a beautiful new studio being
built just taking a little longer than
we thought it was going to and the
acoustics are better in here than they
were in my library so we are going to be
moving into brand new studio so you can
see all that we have lots of other
goodies coming for subscribers if you
become an annual subscriber you get a
free signed copy of say it
so Papa Dabney in the 2005 White Sox
championship season if you didn't get
your dad a Father's Day gift and you
will remit can fix all that by getting
him an annual subscription or to get
yourself the annual subscription and
give him the book you know a free signed
copy or if you just want to listen later
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud give us
a listen subscribe give us a rating we
always appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the country
you